welcome to this video playing Grand
Master conan conan this is some party
grass right Missy a polygraph yeah
that's a 2600 GM let's see what he's
doing there open he is playing the open
the soil I'll play this kalashnikov's
oops I'd that's very uncommon the
capture I wanted to play the Kalashnikov
variation but it didn't happen he took
on c6 interestingly enough ok so what
what am I doing here I can play d 6 I
can yum F for maybe is coming all this I
can play anyway and maybe you can no
okay I just thought maybe can somehow
retreat the night take it to a four or
something and let my bishop look stupid
only seven but while night air force
just completely completely bonkers I can
play well should I try to be greedy in
this position come on I'm greedy playing
g5 and Knight takes e4 I it probably
won't end well but it it is always
tempting okay what is he doing now don't
tell me you take on f6 yeah and just
give me it is doing that just gives me a
good strategically yeah I'm fine fine
position I think with ok i will really
expect attempt to to to sacrifice this
spawn and here black is just very
comfortable ok or d5 form yeah it should
be ok playing in the center
and really want to take an a7
ok
I wonder I wonder I wonder can I kind of
just play for four in the tech here
maybe they are probably many good moves
here not quite sure what's the best just
attacking you for trying to get him to
take on d5 with the pawn now it's doing
that okay so that's very nice nicely
Center light centralized I'm position
it's got Queen III though getting the
Queen begin to play but they have a
great center and should be okay yeah
really there's even look aged three here
this is dangerous what are you doing
against the smooth takes this Queenie
earth rechecking g1 bishop 83 and you're
mated 1g2 or not take on d5 at the end
but ok this is still a good position I
believe
and then you're not going to play g3
here I think he's playing all the moves
I don't expect him to play but I know
that already I have played him a number
of times and I never understand any of
the moves it's just sometimes it is like
that you play even against a strong
player and you don't you don't ever get
what he's doing and this is just one of
those cases okay let's let's see I go
here go back to edge so that's not
winning they give this check on a form
f3 Queenie to is not so not winning okay
taking it is also not winning so I'm
going here and then what three nades
five hmm interesting check I don't I
don't see a win at the moment which
feels strange but I don't see a flat-out
win maybe here I don't want to invest
any more time must move I don't think he
can prevent me from taking on edge to it
should be it should be very dangerous I
mean maybe he has some sort of defense
don't really see anything I can just
take age to next move what is this move
Bishop d5 should I prevent that with the
form i also have rook c8 I've rook c8
this is probably simple and good I hope
winning a tempo when III could have gone
right away so it cannot be a
disadvantage to have the rukon see it
probably has something like that and
what now I take on edge too should takes
Bishop takes Queen takes there is no
maid I cannot believe it time morning
before maybe can I do before prepare
that
now know gage to is again a threat
huh look do you wanna I can take it on
edge too I already can something like g4
I can take with the Queen er this is not
not defending at all okay check okay
check check here also roots III at the
end of all of it or do you for checking
i don't know i mean 47 seconds yeah
that's the real problem King takes this
rook the 8th yeah that's nice I just
want loop the eighth I don't I don't see
a direct win at the moment probably I'm
just overlooking something
to I can take f3 now boo piedra guide
winning the Queen check check check I
don't mind this is winning king and porn
and game whoo that's easier to play even
I'm sorry really I got a slight cord 20
seconds it's not not so easy I don't see
a win at the moment probably I'm just
totally brain-dead check wyd well no
it's a win but that was I was totally
confused for a moment what did I do
wrong here to make it to make it more
difficult I mean okay I of course after
f5 I can just take it this is necessary
much easier but I came ok ok I course I
just need to go to deform oh sorry I was
I was it was a bit confused i can just
do this of course and go here after that
I have this temple move yeah just
sometimes you're just completely a
completely stupid with no time but I was
was really fascinated how easy allowed
all this like all those moves this this
one the tempo I mean it's clear that i
have got some song summer tech going but
you just played a five hour ok three is
it is a complete wind- eight but yeah it
wasn't it took a while but i played the
right moves yeah okay well this is
winning efore was easier ok but as long
as it winds I don't care
takes yeah and I could have one quick I
oh that's no no surprise Queen g5 was
stronger but this this also won the game
yeah yeah yeah okay i didn't i didn't
play the absolute best continuation but
enough to win alright thanks for
watching